have to go wrath - welcome to haunted
house okay so we play we've been playing
a lot of horror games on this channel
together but I think now it's about time
we play some really hardcore but with a
twist so instead of getting scared we're
gonna spook some other people let's do
it oh oh okay let's poke some people out
ah whoa man this is the scariest game
ever made
look at their eyes what the [ __ ]
ha ha ha ha oh the wiggle the deathblow
rigor that's right I'm a ghost at boo
hoo boo let's finish him off with a
knife stab that [ __ ] tree I mean keep
spoken umm keeps poking up who am i
beautiful hi guys what do you guys
I don't know like me wait for it wait
for it wait for it wait for it wait for
sports
oh no the tentacle sign anything but the
tentacles
oh [ __ ] that's nasty they just like it
like yeah that's pretty hot that's one
[ __ ] final affair [ __ ] oh sure he
going down the basement big mistake
spoke spoke spoke Oh that'd kill him
I think I killed him awesome all right
these guys are spooked off in there
already let's go to another place what
did we unlock a character oh when you
kill someone you get a new character
whoa but I prefer the other one I like
him it's not killed he's like I don't
give a [ __ ] about anything all right
what's going on here guys can I be this
whoa I'm a creepy doll oh yeah whoo what
I can be a duck holy [ __ ]
best game ever ten out of ten eleven are
a million out of ten oh I'm a
breakdancing doll there's nothing more
like it
the spookiest character in the world oh
oh
spokes what the [ __ ] he got a boner that
it that's this hot nice it's like ah
don't look at the boner don't look at it
okay I'm looking at it yes I am the doll
again as oh here's what everyone is holy
[ __ ] all right whatever game oh these
guys are freaking out the window just
came nice on the dog - what can I drop
oh my god I can drop bananas and they
kill him awesome man bananas are just
the scariest thing ever if you think
about it they're pretty [ __ ] scary
don't tell me you've never been scared
of a banana you're just lying to
yourself you haven't well you're just a
badass don't you know my chat I'm a shy
oh oh damn I'm a bottle huh
this is prop hunt ha ha ha I'm a humping
bottle hell yeah you can't [ __ ] with
this find a crack too
it's like your mama Oh best game ever 12
out at 2 million a duck that can quack
like a cat that is just whack
what is duck is on multiple steroids I'm
a spray can I get you
Oh spray sprayed up [ __ ] in the face
that sounded wrong man this game is fun
hello I love a [ __ ] with people I am
the ghost of the polo ball bro look at
this [ __ ] I can be a zebra I can be an
underwater zebra best game ever ten of
nebs games so bias to this game tour
cha-cha-cha choo-choo choo-choo
choo-choo choo-choo digit I am I am the
spawn of Satan so what do you know I'm
just moonwalking hey don't mind may I
what's a scary
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna slice you out of
[ __ ] pieces come I betcha I'll slice
you up yeah that's right I am the spawn
of Satan
oh that's disgusting that's a urine what
the [ __ ] man whoa whoa whoa hell yeah
sar class I'll have a dog didn't give a
[ __ ]
strut that I have strut that ass strut
that strut data strut that ass oh was
the egg hahaha its sperm what the [ __ ]
how is it scary this is sexy let's be
honest come on so we found almost all
the characters let's go one more here
oh so sexy so fabulous mmm mmm watch me
jiggle that when you like it when I
jiggle my ah that's right [ __ ] I'm
vibrating what you're gonna do about it
she has no idea how to handle it huh she
nope my right oh yeah that's right good
vibrations I'll spend - [ __ ] that's all
I know
I was it scary yeah deal
yes we kill him awesome
I think this one is another one
black there we go [ __ ] then so we
only miss one person let's we might as
well try find him oh it's this girl
there we go
cool I think we got all of them and then
they are the entire family portrait so
they were all related huh that's kind of
cute
all right that's a really nice cute
little game I propose enjoyed watching
I'll leave a link if you want to try it
out yourself hit subscribe comment read
today I'll see you in the next one
that's bread love you